hey everybody John Luke here with teh up
expert destiny fan of GameSpot offices
and destiny 2 has finally been
officially revealed today they just had
their brand new trailer rally the troops
yep and they showed off a couple cool
things in it yeah when we get started
with that yeah well break it down a
little bit to the best of our ability so
finally it looks like the Cabal are
going to have a bigger kind of impact in
the Destiny world they appear to be
invading and attacking the tower they've
pretty much destroyed the tower so to
speak and you see zavala Cade 6i core
kind of telling you the story about like
what was happening there and like how
they got to the point that they're at
now where they're trying to rally the
said troops because the tower has fallen
yeah i'm at first i was a little
disappointed kind of hoping for like a
whole new enemy faction but i did kind
of thinking about it realized i like the
Cabal actually haven't really had like a
major sort of like story of their own
yet in the destiny universe so it is
kind of cool to see that they talk about
the enemy the main bad guy is called was
a Gaul not scared Gary definitely good
everyone's gonna be looking for group
for Gary Gary Gary yes absolutely he's
the leader of the red Legion as it says
in the on the website and they do say
you're going to be venturing to
mysterious unexplored worlds in the
solar system to discover an arsenal of
weapons and devastating new combat
abilities so new stuff yeah definitely
going to be new loot as Kate six allude
to at alluded to at the end of the
trailer also there will be a ton of loot
Yeah right
not
yeah definitely going to have hopefully
some new weapons we also saw some old
weapons in the trailer there's some look
online looking weapons some cero's
looking weapons and some Vanguard stuff
but it'll be interesting to see how the
subclasses change for the three main
classes and we don't know if there's any
new classes but for sure on the website
it did show the hunter the Titan the
Warlock yep so hoping for new sub
classes for sure and uh interested to
see what they do with the new loop
because it's such a big integral part of
destiny absolutely i'm definitely i'm
curious about sort of a new unexplored
world like I want to see kind of where
they can take this I'm imagining this is
sort of gonna be like a it's weird like
think I was thinking about this how this
is like a weird parallel to halo 2 we're
like I'm kind of thinking like the
beginning of the game's gonna be like on
earth and then you gotta leave and get
help but then like they actually have to
know this is like their chance to redeem
themselves and actually like come back
and actually like you have climactic
fight on earth rather than like and the
game mayhap anyway I think those
blitzkrieg or blitzkrieg one on reddit
yeah that brought up a pretty
interesting and and kind of cool point
potentially that may be our first raid
in destiny 2 will be in the tower and
maybe we'll scale what's left of the
tower all out like the raid the movie I
would be so into that especially if it's
like the final battles on the courtyard
itself like this iconic location that
like everyone remembers and like that
would that would be so cool yeah that'd
be pretty amazing so yeah there's also
going to be I think the first time where
we're going to see gameplay of destiny
too i think is going to be revealed on
May eighteenth maybe on a live stream by
a bungee so definitely look definitely
looking forward to that but you can
pre-order it now I think there's a
couple different bundles
pick those out yeah check those out so
they're offering a couple things first
off they're already offering the
expansion pass the same way they did
with the first destiny so they're still
doing seems like those small or
expansions as well and there's gonna be
two right in this expansion pass yeah it
says it's offering brand new story
missions cooperative activities
multiplayer and a wealth of new weapons
armor and gear the interesting part is
that they show on the symbols they show
the trials of Osiris symbol and then
they show another symbol that is
apparently it's on the grimoire card for
Rasputin so yeah it's like the warmind
symbol so maybe like a little expansion
relating to the war mines as well which
that makes sense like wanting to have
the war- be involved yeah they've kind
of tapped that maybe not tapped is the
right word but they've kind of alluded
to some of that Rasputin storyline and
some of the warm line stuff but they
haven't like really dived into it yet so
it would be interesting to see once that
expansion pack comes out but yeah they
have a lot of like story threads they've
kind of been like left open at the end
of destiny and like I want to see
obviously the other factions are going
to be in the game as well so like you
know like the taken King kind of left
things open and maybe they will continue
that storyline necessarily we're kind of
like start to hint at like other stuff
past this this first thing with the red
Legion and like where the game could go
from there would be that pretty cool um
I guess the only other thing I can think
of in terms of just watching the trailer
was I mean this is a small thing but
after seeing kind of zavala I Cora and
Cade 6 kind of giving their speeches in
a way i quartered not so much but Cade
6ins of all I'm wondering if you know
how they had dead orbit new monarchy
future war clock maybe they don't do
that anymore in terms of clans but maybe
they base it off of like zavala Cade six
I Cora I don't know if they'll do that
but that seems kind of interesting in a
way I guess yeah I mean there I think
they're definitely going to give them
more character focus for sure that was
something they were already starting to
do but like the taken King and I think
they're really just going to continue to
expand on that like
I and they're they're really like the
website emphasized them is like they're
the leader of each different you know
like class you know the hunter in the
vanguard and warlock so like I think
maybe the idea of more class specific
missions with them could maybe be like
it like a faction kind of way could be
really cool yeah definitely and I guess
the one other thing that confirmed today
it's pretty big news is is finally gonna
make it a PC yes which is big for you i
know that i'm struggling right now I
don't know which one to pick so at first
I was like wow maybe he'll get ps4 all
my friends at ps4 and then like a
message my friend Siddharth guys which
version are you getting they're all like
yeah we're getting pc I'm like ah and I
don't know especially because
PlayStation still has those exclusives
it says on the website that there is
gonna be exclusive content it's still
that one year thing so whatever
PlayStation gets everyone else won't get
till at least fall of two thousand 18
which it's like oh man like I don't know
like am I gonna miss that stuff am I
gonna miss that extra those extra guns
and I don't know yeah and and we won't
know to in terms of like there is gonna
be a beta obviously we're guessing maybe
june ish or so not confirmed obviously
but it would make sense because before i
have more information about the game at
e3 as well yes and said more details
will simply specifically some more
details about the PlayStation exclusives
in the summer which very much implies so
any press conference gotta have it
reveal there's my guess but yeah they
said the beta is just some time later in
the summer no no official release date
they did say however it is an open beta
so the early access you get through
pre-order just seems like you get it
like maybe like a week or two early but
they are gonna have it open for everyone
which is that's that's pretty crazy yeah
kind of curious to if they'll ever have
a closed one before that maybe maybe not
um maybe ps4 gets that little like 12
day exact start over everyone but um
yeah why don't you guys leave us your
comments your thoughts on what you think
of the destiny 2 trailer and what you
guys want in destiny to hit that
subscribe button and follow us for more
coverage of destiny too thanks gently
thanks a see you guys later
[Music]